if you want Fitness if you want you like
fitness feed your my goodness I am
Fitness mistaken your mouth huh see no
because that wouldn't be considered
Fitness food and I don't like the way
you're talking right now
now there's a home workout and I can do
it for you you think you can deep throat
when those steel clubs no I don't want
to try that and that's not what those
honest steel clubs are for Brendan I'm
saying unless you're really into that
and then they are using the bottom line
they do have the best exercise
functional fitness equipment there is
dude what if you'll have a gym and
you're put on the quarantine ten then
work out with your clubs and maces or
what about with the on-demand training
you got a living room you got a garage
drags you [ __ ] yeah on the six barbell
on at six bodyweight battle remains
Fitness save 10% dude I just got a
shitload of the on it and the black
rifle coffee the kick-ass coffee [ __ ] oh
my god the [ __ ] yeah coffee it is the
old tooth the old tooth but when you get
that [ __ ] yeah coffee you'll grind your
[ __ ] teeth I'll take off your
trousers you'll start a business and rob
a bank robbing tank on that that's what
happens when you eat [ __ ] yeah coffee
you [ __ ] you rob a bank you start a
business I call success all down - [ __ ]
yeah coffee and kill Brian oh good it
[ __ ] down yep [ __ ] a coffee and
I'll put you in a guard and squeeze your
stupid head dude you're 42 [ __ ] yeah
coffee makes me gay I'll drink that a
cup of [ __ ] yeah coughing oh and I will
[ __ ] start your face you can't [ __ ]
start my face that's super rude you
piece of [ __ ] you guys when I [ __ ]
drink coffee
and [ __ ] your face like it's a bike
here's the problem there's problem when
I drink [ __ ] a coffee I grind my
teeth so you stick that dick in my mouth
and I'm gonna be grinding my teeth cuz
that caffeine gets me going next so I
hope your dick is diamond hard because I
got some strong jaw muscles
only one way to find out you old [ __ ]
what audit calm / fighter 10% off or gay
no [ __ ]
yeah you don't even know all right man
you don't to be rude about it didn't no
I'm just saying dude let's let's just
start rolling cuz I got a lot to say
right now I'm coming in hot
I'm pissed already at you guys so first
of all welcome to the mother of all
podcasts right oh you started already
you have to say you were about to say
something that you couldn't down there
it's my favorite thing so before we do
this podcast Brandon I catch up and a
lot of times it's stuff that you just
can't air cuz we're guys yeah let's go
back Shh you guys will do it we every
time we do an episode he's always
looking at can you cut that part no we
you know what we really don't edit ever
now we could do this thing live are we
whisking it up yeah well I haven't eaten
a thing boys are here man you guys drink
whiskey do you do you like the best
whiskey in the world it's the best
mustache you drink whiskey yeah the best
whiskey in the world right now I want to
get a couple of things that annoy me
already
Brent we just started Brent Britton the
problem with the name like Brent is it's
the same name as Craig no it's not
that's Greg or Craig I mean I don't be
Brett bread or Brent well yelling don't
be either one of those names maybe
change and also you have a mustache okay
first off don't compare me to a Craig or
Greg all right Brent is exotic there's
something about him or he's a rich
[ __ ] you don't know who he is there's
two different white guys or a fun black
guy there are no that's a great black
guy yeah I've never met her but I don't
think there's a black guy in the world
named Brent went to junior high school
with to Brent's I don't think so black
one was half black
don't say boy you said it at night Long
Beach we I'm from Connecticut so that
doesn't that's a that's what are you
doing 500 are we sippin alright you're a
little out of hand
you got a supplies can ask off the guys
out of hand get yours Kling keys [ __ ]
man Kling keys it's the best whiskey in
the world I'm not joking tomorrow hey
thanks to my to my karate homies we got
a corona homies dude I think Corona and
I think the moustache sometimes a Corona
makes sense there's nothing else to do I
thought about altar I thought about it
the filter
god damn it is really good wow that is
real smooth you want us closer yeah six
feet bro wow I like this is six feet
yeah we're told you guys record it
I'm Negron's alley we built the studio
like brass to do City at breath house
real city I'm gonna melon myself you are
yo I'm starting to learn that a lot of
people are in the valley and I did just
don't talk to me you know little Bobby
Lee Santino I don't see them well you
know a little Bobby yeah now you guys
are stand-up comics Brian we know we
know you're here and you know I'm a
stand-up comic you can't you know come
on try to follow me hey hey Jason Jason
don't be cocky honest in this car they
call me the machine gun we don't call
you that let me see [ __ ] never right
never heard that never heard it the
people could you talk too fast if we
can't understand your bits that's how
what it is Oh guys you know what this is
prior 1,000 mod cast yeah hello yes a
million dollars call me when you're
serious you know that you didn't answer
it hey you know you didn't slide that
over who was that hey how about this I
deleted since we all know Taliah very
well here yeah to Liautaud Rogen's
podcast and he went to the thing and of
course Rogan does a three-hour podcast I
got there just in time and I should have
gotten there earlier cuz guess who ran
out of [ __ ] things to say Chris Chris
D'Elia
well yeah yup and guess who ran an
energy he just goes yep and one point I
looked him I went oh you just you just
lost everything he goes I got hungry I'm
hungry three hours is too long Chris
yeah
power feel said it best he did Rogan and
the first time doing rowing communist
he was umbrella I'm gonna talk to my dad
long in three hours
that's once ever talk to me with my life
that's all they wanted yeah I don't have
an attention span like that either I
never get tired when I talk to go three
hours spin you know we did three hours
and thirty minutes I think they thought
that's cuz I'm deep and I'm expansive in
my knowledge yes I'm talking about like
stuff it's like very it I remember one
time I hung out with you and dove
Davidoff yeah and we went out to it for
a drink the three of us yeah
you two just talked about pygmies yeah
wait for and I'm talking about
philosophy and you were looking and
Jason it was like this he's like this
and then and then tough goes hey stop
talking about this [ __ ] the guy's not
interested in you never said this stuff
does great yeah it's great pushed a warm
bottle of milk in your mouth remember
that yeah Jason where was that was it
Nashville Nashville that's right
Brent I were there man right you guys
had staggered shows and since I was
there they just had me jump on right
it's a fun show yeah - feels great was
that the night that I went and hung out
with John Cleese yes oh yeah how much
guys he's got great stories he's got
that great voice Python yeah I also had
to throw that in there didn't I had
nothing to do about 37 oh you're young
you know 38 no 37-32 I'm older yeah
March 18 1983 I just saw myself on sexy
I was really six I hated myself but how
long ago was that would you play in Sex
in the City
abuela waiter you're the rabbit on a
circle and Howie Hornstein around a guy
who has a one-night stand with Carrie I
give her a sex sprain and then she blows
me off and I'm really sensitive so they
look at you and you were 36 at the time
I was 36 and I just that was 1997 and
this is what Jude Law was a [ __ ] right
so you're trying to a that's right Jude
Law
I'm not being shitty that's a compliment
he was sexy and he had a [ __ ] together
I'll worry hey he was the man though you
used your hair by tho get like nine
moves in one year do you think I think
so here's why the yes I don't get mad I
live here too like my hair is so
annoying during this quarantine by the
way it just keeps my pouring out of my
head but your hair now it looks like it
this is on purpose like okay like the
way you had it before where you were
trying to do a style yeah man
it was I knew what you were trying to do
I know it was you were going for this
but no I'm being honest because it now
this is where you need to be because now
it's like you're it's almost like you're
you're preparing for what's next to come
yes it's a good head and you're doing
gracefully you're doing a shot guard do
a Sean Connery do it Jason yeah and go
do what's happening gracefully I don't
want to say balding cuz that's mean but
and I'm and I'm thick now I'm thick if
you see my the last Instagram post I
posted against Chris Oh with the white
you see what I see how menacing I look
with two knives do I feel like Chris is
put on some weight right yeah honestly
everybody its young steroid he's he's
Juicin boy he's scared of liquor little
loan steroids yeah he's got a hell thick
no but I want a membership to his garage
man yeah I know that's incredible look
it up oh yeah look at him that air it is
I think Swartz Anette a really good and
that isn't my drama I'm all trapped you
know what you look like then that pic
you look up to a cholo in that picture
yeah you look like a la very strange
maybe you can see I'm ready and Chris is
literally dressed like me when he used
to make fun of the way I dress all this
also looks like you didn't want to take
that picture yeah exactly 101 that's
that's a samurai sword from the 1500s I
Got News for him you should always say
it's not you say that the life it's not
because he was told that but it's it's
it's not in fact it was made probably
five years ago in some factory but well
I'm gonna let him own even though that
though because because look this up chin
samurai swords from the 1500s anybody
who'd practiced Bushido and and was a
true samurai who she is
these the metal was folded it's phone
that's not folded metal [ __ ] now that's
some [ __ ] stainless steel first two
hundred thousand how do you how can you
tell the difference
no scroll up he is right there I
practice yuge i practicing Kenshin
Japanese samurai swords three grand in
though
three grand son no that's not a real
candidate sword fighting fifteenth
century really sounds like a a gambling
why would it be two hundred grand I
don't know I figured that their Museum
made all this up huh let me show you
hundred grand I should get some songs
sound the metal is folded no I don't
know what you're talking about this what
is that I believe Rogan I don't know
Brennan because from from wooden five
hundred years old are you guys telling
me that it would look like that yeah I
don't think you carat metal yeah metal
metal wasn't it wasn't a cure listen was
it stainless steel I know I will never
draw my sword unless I'm I'm gonna draw
blood well
come on portfolio basically makes the
steel more uniform throughout the blades
length modern smelting can achieve
things up with more quality still use an
agent smelting huh always and you know
that [ __ ] that can you get more samurai
swords will buy one for the [ __ ] air
Bryan's we know that just by looking at
it yeah I know by dodging in touch so so
I know now listen when you understand
blades when you win a blade is real and
it can cut look at that you touch it you
go there you go 220,000 there that's
what I mean and I listen man when you
touch it it's like this it's so cold
that it burns to sleep like that and
that's what I'm see what I'm saying
that's a 225 that's a museum relic to
get the real deal is museums I've looked
6 grand 4 grand I don't even I don't
think that's what I get a million dollar
sword Oh somebody plans right you know
someone museum piece a million dollars
it's a real samurai sword why are you
saying it like that sorry cuz I speak
you're showing right now you see this
blade you see what I mean yeah he'll
know that there was an ancient that was
an ancient smelting technique mm-hmm and
you and your maken we smell you might
have probably
just point something out though about
all this like they were making swords
back then when they didn't have the
technology to make them like better like
they can now so why is that more than
like now it's a relic and it's from then
and it's it is sad have you remember
those those swords I won't get in the
right lane with you remember the five
raised by mu multimeter she well I
apologize and a great deal about they're
not [ __ ] Japanese I'm just sayin you
just lumped in Vietnamese and Koreans
with Japanese the more insulting to
boats a little trance of what you're
doing I'm speaking Japanese I'm not
pronouncing it new multiple sir she is
the way you say his name you say alright
I was gonna ask you guys if he's saying
it right but then that's what you said
it kind of doing it I said it cut out
they for many many years you he had a
school that's a martial arts school
seven yeah in the in the 90s in early
were some in the malls no I did all
outdoor like strip malls what did you
guys teach Kempo karate in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu oh when I saw you it when we
were in Nashville you told the story
about when the first time you saw boys
Gracie yeah I don't know if I told you
them but he was my first instructor oh
really yep a lot me jiu-jitsu lessons
from Hoyts for my 21st birthday yeah all
lit up and I got to take lessons with
him and his dad damn I took lessons
directly from Elio a few times yeah
that's right there touring school damn
man it was awesome there's this guy when
he was at that time he was in it he was
80 something and just little and looked
frail but man there was a class we were
doing a class and he came in as the
guest instructor and he was gonna to
through the basic guard pass move he was
just gonna show us how to do the basic
guard path and this young guy he gets
his calls this young guy over and put
some he the guy puts le on his guard
voices translating cuz he's not speaking
English and he starts to show the move
and the kid starts resisting and he kind
of looks at boys and says something
horses yo don't resist he's just yeah
she's showing the move right now oh okay
goes to do it again kid resists again
big kid by the way oh it says like you
got to stop resisting trust me you don't
you don't want to do that
okay goes to do the guard pass again kid
resists again
elio this tiny little man grabs him by
the gay picks him all the way up this
big kid and slams him yeah everybody in
the room we're just well I mean if I
mean it was if you didn't have respect
for him yeah
before that it was insane I would make
the argument and maybe you can talk
speak to this it in terms of he was a
genius in a lot I mean what he created
his genes yeah he was it also it also
changed martial arts in every aspect of
the game right well it's changed martial
arts when in ninety it was at 92 the
first UFC 1992 that I started studying
jujitsu before that and there was no but
nobody was there it was like a room no
bigger than this they only allowed six
people at a time to hook to a class so
there wouldn't be crowded then the UFC
happened the next thing you know my kind
of martial arts schools we're going out
of business you're going out of business
if you didn't learn I'll fight it use it
let's be honest apparently not in the
UFC karate tae kwon know you know DLC
put although wouldn't you say that that
Taekwondo and karate are good basis to
like so I'd say before spear a really
more space but what about what they're
good tower in my opinion is heated
champion
here's what war is what you learn a lot
you learn you learn body control you
definitely learn balance and you learn
how these learn sad I think it's better
a lot of guys
what about it's better than nothing a
lot of people have a hard time doing
something with their right hand in
something with their foot at this yeah I
think it so Chi they because you learn
that she'll people say that's their back
room that's what they got him when they
were kids think you got anything they
scope in the fight I started doing
karate yet okay well I mean what else
you gonna do yeah I started doing karate
I chose the worst base to have them
really if you have wrestling or Jitsu
yeah see that because their habits yeah
right
also in in those competitions there's
always a guy stopping you it's basically
a sophisticated game of tag yes no one's
getting money especially point fighting
you're not learning how to take a punch
that's why I started doing like when I
actually kind of had a little bit of a
disagree with my Kempo instructor
because I decided I wanted to fight so I
started doing full contact karate
matches where you're you know it's not
points yeah did that for like five
minutes no Mike this isn't for me
and then at 21 I started taking jujitsu
and that's when it like everything for
me but it changed everything jiu-jitsu
changed everything
yeah this one little dude came up just
genius and then yeah so much of it was a
derivative but it's almost like you have
to know some jiu-jitsu if you want to be
yeah yeah but then everybody learned it
and it was like when the UFC first came
out it was like watching bloodsport
brand it was literally what do you think
about combat why don't you jump in here
oh no get me outta UFC fight talk please
are you into an hour but you how are you
Thomas let me ask you this are you a
like that with your just you're done no
I'm not done I got done it's very
vanilla or people don't know what their
time but I don't want to you know I got
I don't want break down on bikes with
you guys
people wanted to talk more sports with
me and I because when I stopped doing
martial arts I you know what it's not
fun not lace not silly yeah like
especially when it's your [ __ ] job
it's not me I only do it once a week so
I don't for me it was my business yeah
and I was like I don't want to talk
about it anymore no I don't mind it yeah
come on I don't I actually stopped
watching it all together for years like
I'm so uneducated on really do you watch
no I started again but then it's just
honestly stand-up comedy took over
everything
yeah that's literally all I gave a [ __ ]
about for the long isn't that more fun
it's way more fun I actually went to his
class when we were first friends Dave I
met you and alia when I was 18 19 huh
and the other was that he's 33 15 oh so
whatever you're gonna say you had a
record man no no no he did I had record
interest and I've written songs and
stuff but is a better voice here he does
what yeah what's your tongue
I don't know oh yeah he's very armed
being I'm more like I'm more like a
white guy who singing about the girl
that's here one of your white guys song
give me that you gonna do it no I think
allowing them all right let me see I
don't know what that Larry goes what you
gonna do that sounds like it's because I
can't do that what comes on what comes
after you do well my cue and then you
add to that and then you add to it oh
yeah man let me see you guys come time
you start you start then you gonna do
Murray start then used and then you
finish then you so good do it I always
try to do I release the worst music
director ever Brett let me be the
director ready guys we're gonna improv a
song here okay and we've got Jason
Collings and I'd say a lot of people
think it's already born well it's Brent
I'm your friend
yes dig in each other taking time to
talk it over that was my father
my dad had a hit single 19 sir yeah I
still have his recording on an American
Bandstand with his interview with Dick
Clark oh that's cool that's yeah it's a
song we use for our podcast now I got a
record deal when I was 19 years old but
it wasn't for singing it was for I was
producing hip hop music yeah Jason was
very very long only to work with I
worked with a guy out of Island Records
and he had a little subsidiary called
true sound and they signed us for a
little production do the my only claim
to fame really is back in the day you
might remember this because of your age
but um back in the day on HBO
it was Forest Whitaker's directorial
debut he had an HBO movie called
strapped yep
remember that movie love for us all the
movies I got produced the music you did
it was I did all the background really
what's cool that's [ __ ] yeah that's
right and I had another kid and then it
was time to open a martial arts school
in that said when I opened my school
yeah look at that movie man educate
these [ __ ] yeah let's do a song
together man
isolate it's not find a good song you
guys can sing me a lot
he's your guy voice tonight was yes and
then I worked with one of their music
directors back in the day but there was
a I don't know how old you are but those
are tour called the triple threat tour
and it was boys too it was uh it was BBD
keith sweat and sweat wooden uh boys to
men
nice and it was yeah was that when
they're like all past their prime and
then like epsilon tortilla no no there
was this was still on BB D was big
thankful they were good any morning
that's what they do now run kids on the
block your backstreet ain't go on tour
together what's crazy trills yeah Bell
Biv DeVoe I thought BBD just talked
about this you're just our party eyes
chin hate your music
what's your pie yes coach the lion's den
that lies then oh yeah rent worn in
chasing cars there's no other reason
other than the fact that it's in his den
and there's pictures of lions on them I
already had lines were down oh you're
like set ah [ __ ] the Michener yeah this
isn't mine you're not like you're good
you know it's just stories
Wow I mean the mood lighting my god are
you really
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll sing about singing yeah next time
don't bring up singing and then go hey
open this [ __ ] up what is that song
that's George Michael one more try hey
whoa you know I'm good Bryan me let me
see that hit that note again it did one
the way you just did
there I go there I go there I go there I
go you know the song right no but it
sounds pretty baby you control that's
all high school [ __ ] oh my kids Ryan cuz
Irene didn't like open images once upon
a time on Ocean Avenue honey you need
the great singers tiger King oh that
dude is amazing it wasn't his voice
obviously I was like man but then I
liked the [ __ ] then we found a nice
sauna disappoint on the into singing
worth when you just haven't done I wish
I it feels good okay well what was the
thing I watch you do the danzig when I
sang mother yeah but what show goddamn
Comedy Jam I love that show yeah yeah
that was fun Utah I won I was the best
what does it call the winds at the end
what what was that again nothing what
does it call when everybody stands at
the end what Jason the first time I did
it I sang taking it to the streets for
the doobie brother that's a great song
and it was fun how do you do that
you know me but the second time I did it
I did superstition by Stevie Wonder you
sang that song that was you know it yeah
very superstitious show with daliyah oh
yeah beat him listen I've seen that the
lip-sync battle that was fun man he
hates when I win with this did a
lip-sync battle with her battle off you
want song yeah got the belt
so instead oh I want to see that because
I thought to leave [ __ ] Slough that
slew that really play it on air that's a
bummer honestly I thought I was gonna
lose cuz Chris moves in like has a Gumby
body was so good but then when Chrissy
Teigan told me the way to win is you
just gotta get the audience alike and I
was like well he's so unlikable I could
to get the audience hey that's our
friend we're talking about one hand in
the pocket odds after you why do you
want wait who is that it's Christian
tell the one with the belt on oh that's
me oh that's you to win the title
is a humbling experience I know I could
do it I didn't know who these pots
guiding me along play the real dish
we'll have a home plate where they cut
my moonwalk tell him what you did when
it wasn't when you were not on really
hurt
what like off air did you like do ha oh
yeah they try to win the crowd over I
said huh she said during the commercial
breaks you got to try to get the
audience to like you because they vote
and so I said Yoel which I don't know if
he's ever been called el I said let me
rap for you that's how I freestyle
wrapped for for LL Cool J really which
is another thing Chris hates that I do
so I was just really there to rap dude
hey what is that oh they make us
dailymotion but I don't know if I can
fast forward here oh I talked about his
divorce and [ __ ] Oh was he stripping how
did you guys rehearse this her husband
oh yeah well I'll be you get like an
hour to rehearse so I was off oh wow
right oh no oh no what I've never
Christy Teegan yeah yeah that's cute hey
I tried this oh no way off way off I had
an hour not singer Larry gave you an
hour yeah you get no time because you do
it all in the day some let you and you
weren't lip-synching right there no
because I got one thing at a time Jake
that's why they go low were you
moonwalking I was that's why they cheer
but they went up they were like this kid
is just doing a lot of arms cool skinny
tied to that's a great idea also you
know the songs a little slow right now
they slow it down like to me it looks
like all about the [ __ ] pounds whoa
that hurt my neck so manse hey Brian all
right
you know I can't you know what I could
do I could do like if I was in a
Broadway show right the girls can dance
I've never seen this you have it no I'm
sorry actually haven't seen it either
sick this slowdown bit all right yeah it
is slowed down because I definitely we
were definitely moving quick the ship is
like imagine it like 10 times faster
because right now it just looks like
we're real yes
rent how to dance this is very
make-a-wish oh you touched your feet oh
that's very good
well it actually fell out so I was
covering it up that's that's no still
going on I don't know but I will tell
you this it actually was funny [ __ ] like
you two would be great on it to do it
you know Ryan you got dance moves they
just throw [ __ ] into it they go like
okay so what song you want to do is
telling the song ago okay so we got 11
dancers we're gonna do a desk we got
that's like what and they're like oh
yeah we put so much into the production
it's like wow man that's kind of fun and
then you wrap and then Chris lost and it
really bothered him and really bother
that's like I beat him in and we did
this stupid competition to see who get
that loudest laughs at the Laugh Factory
I [ __ ] beat him yeah and I went after
him and then I I go like this I could
look at him I go hey Chris
so it's done crazy and then I posted it
he did not he was like get you up
I was [ __ ] with the most like hey bro
sorry man Ali play with my crown and my
robes in the card oh yeah I just never
got an answer that's funny he's
competitive oh yeah try this real quick
this is like 30 seconds okay so this
[Music]
yeah Ted faster yeah why were they doing
the nerd theme I I think I was like I
like oh that was cute the other way was
backwards was it veteran you know bypass
the hoe God that stuff everybody's so
cool I don't know anything about that
[ __ ] I don't know why I said that and
again went over on someone you know what
I think about I think about the Comedy
Store like back in the day like when it
was actually empty you remember like
back then and one of my few doesn't
remember that it was so it was so empty
all the time my favorites though where
the late night sets when no one's there
on Brian
you teaching in front of seven people
and then me and like the Lea and Jay and
people in the back row or the comics
sitter like 1:00 a.m. on a Tuesday
teaching Brian Callens dance class
by the way just doing ballet in front of
seven people grown man people enjoy it
I did that for years I I get 30 minutes
for an Israeli guy who is like one guy
one guy at home the morning he was like
this I'm just [ __ ] killing with one
guy I just very good though
oh I was committing to every joke I have
a workout I was sweaty when I bad do you
miss stand-up oh oh my god if it wasn't
for podcasting I'd be losing my with
Rogan and Aaliyah yesterday Rogan Rogan
is such a dooms there rogue is like I
don't thing we're coming back till 2020
yeah honey wiser 22 come on no I just
had a conversation and then yet but he
has a show in math Square Garden in
October I'm like public that's not yeah
happen yeah we have a few things anova
then again yeah I have something in July
that I hope so I have some end of end of
June in Spokane Washington
I love [ __ ] no I'm just I'm that's what
I love about him how uh knit well he
just doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like I'm
huh I have a show at the end of June in
Spokane and it's happening and you know
what March everything was when
everything I can't so I was like oh
honey I was okay at first and then yeah
yeah it's a lot in I can't wait to go
back when this I don't think the people
at home know when you're a comic you're
used to doing it every night so you kind
of lose it I can't wait to go to the
store and just watch super okay but it's
gonna be like the how it was it how it
used to be at the store
that original room was my favorite room
cuz you could [ __ ] around in there and
then I could try [ __ ] out now it's like
this different thing where I feel like
yo I got to get up in your a game
go in the O R now which it wasn't joke
it used to be a pleasure it was work
[ __ ] house against Jim it was nearly a
chimp I did a whole set laying down on
the in there one time just literally
laying down on the thing just to see
what would happen I did a whole set in a
fake language one night I just went up
in my whole set I was like okay he would
get up and go he would get up and do my
kicks my high kicks Oh Lance can't stop
Lance can't stop let's do this guy who
was like about his karate and yeah he
wanted to be an action movie star and
then
open it open it up for questions he's
like ask me any question you have and
somebody would go on for a while right
my favorite was somebody said who are
your two biggest influences he said
that's easy Michael Jackson jean-claude
Van Damme magic that would happen it
still is of course it is yeah it's just
I know it's like yeah now it's it's
because podcasting has created such a
global appetite
whenever anybody from any country any
country comes they go to the Comedy
Store because it's become such a thing
we all talk about it yeah that's true
that's standing-room-only it's kind of
incredible its success years we would go
there and I remember they would give you
a 15 dollar check yeah and Rogan had his
entire wall covered in 15 dollar checks
I think that's great yeah he never ever
cashed one and it would just be it was
just that weird place man going here my
clubs here me shutting down because of
the economy yeah why so let me sort be
fine yeah nobody shall be fine laughs
factory should be fine any frogs should
be fine but I did see something where
lighthouse is fine ice house will be
fine that it's owned by a millionaire
but he billionaire but I saw the
flappers is is really worried yeah
flappers the stuff that was always
worried this as the looking Club it's
not a beautiful location and sometimes
the the lineups were I don't know
there's some other places like the
mom-and-pop shops like hopefully like
wiseguys and you have allies guys I'm
looking about white guys think about
think about out of I got a call
California yeah you think about are also
like what about places that are super
popular but there's just a one they're
not part of a big chain like cap city
yeah you think they're gonna be yeah I
hope so they've been around so cobbs in
San Francisco landmarks man yeah it does
it doesn't work that way if you guys
want to break into AMC and watch them
but I think I could work the projector
AMC I believe they're bankrupt they're
bankrupt that's a good thing though
because sometimes the lineups make you
just go you know we just watch a movie
upstairs
here's the good news I'm serious about
but here's the deal
a lot of that a lot of thing I'll places
who crave I got arrested like Netflix
you get senior their own stomata brenda
Netflix they're running out of content
I'm running out of new content well I
just started watching Mad Men again or
not believe it or not so they're gonna
need new content oh yeah the other crazy
things are so many movies that are huge
movies in the waiting to be released
like my friends Wonder Woman - oh yeah
you you you are not going to see that
until it comes out it'll when is it
gonna come out yeah I know idea some
movies are streaming now on you could
like movies that were out on the theater
like the Invisible Man I just watched
trolls and trolls is out and also I
started richard $20 about seven times
they're making Bank oh that's right kids
it's just really rent oh why is that
many times my son just how obsessed with
it for you can convince yourself because
we go the movies it's gonna be 15 bucks
a ticket but she don't take some yeah
that's how I justify because I also want
to troll 7 times around children with
that monster ABC I'm not around anyone
that's me you all by yourself yeah now
when you were in the mirror did you when
when did you say I'm gonna grow a
mustache I'll tell you this I had it and
then I can I tell you this I don't like
when people start a sentence with I'll
tell you this I had it had to shave it
for some acting thing and then I grew up
back and then today I was actually
shaving I said I'm gonna see if it's
long enough and then it's not but I was
like oh I'm just gonna go no one will
say anything and I took my mask off and
the first thing you said was I'll shave
that before we start okay so I dig it
I love mustache would you do would you
do handlebar no no no nothing hope you I
call that one a crust - that's what that
one I hate man I'm working on it it's
gonna take another week and then it will
get to like why don't you get a thin one
super thin see how that works out or get
do a real shortage see what happens okay
it'll look great with your blue eyes I
talked about how you admire modern
German history's a really good smooth
Bowl everything what do you guys talk
about on the podcast just love it dude
politics
we do hey dude how long have you guys
talking about how much we just had our
20th episode that's already 2010 news
and it's already great Apple it's
amazing alright the Lions it's amazing
we have fans all over all right so give
us a sample of what you got how you guys
start and go and go so what you do how
you been what do you mean what have you
been asked to be on the show no me
neither
absolutely both of you are [ __ ] live
it I approached you in the hallway and
you gave me one of these a cumin and
then walked away you piss one keep lying
because not even two pistols single guys
on the flip rolled out
yeah about you honestly not Dennis Quaid
said yes before any of our friends
Dennis Quaid said Brad Garrett they were
going to but then the rhone roan
happened yeah moroni it's it's a rare
breed when Brian said he has come in
studios like I like those guys yeah so
won't do it
he we're gonna we're gonna yeah [ __ ]
hell [ __ ] Dhulia nasty I go dude for
your special yeah come in the week
before us dude I'm not leave my house
you know I would
and then Rogan I did rogue on Thursday
cuz you know who's in there on Tuesday
who he goes D'Elia I got that
[ __ ] episode what he got tested
to get raw we just had all got tested he
has a doctor come in pricks your finger
and testing for antibodies like you're
going out came from your boy did so yet
start I did it first why don't all
Brogan said not foolproof and stuff
because people working more on Theodore
look at Falls roof by the way Brian
that's foolproof what I say you said
foolproof
fall fall proof foolproof fool I know
it's real all proof I say foolproof no
you said foolproof
oh I have a speech impediment I guess no
not like 9 NIACC you have no excuses
oh we had a we had an episode about CT
we had Kerry Rhodes on who's ex NFL
football player and we talked about the
quarterback yeah
was same yeah and what do you say about
it he thinks that that most people have
it pretty much if you've gotten bang in
the head at least one time in your life
it's pretty good chance to you how does
yeah but but guys are the majority guys
are fun yeah I his mouth
what you did for man what a smile well
he has some chompers on him huh
um handsome man so he so he's he worried
about it no man what's he acting and I
know what what's his uh all right hang
on bro blow is that yeah I love her
she's a dog she's a great girl
okay all right she's a positive attitude
well here's the biggest mouth in the
world who is that guy with the muscles
hit click on that there's a light guy
that's one that guy right there yeah
click on that that's the body right the
guy's Mike on the right I don't know
interest well if those two white girl
got banged out all right what is also
immature say his name I mean Vegas all
the time at a pool if I have aronia gut
right now quarantine 10 on I got a last
episode I watched it oh my god damn it I
got a Buddha Corona go yes Carol does he
have does he got stud
yeah acting he's singing - its he
released a single huh he's a great guy
let's judge it um chasing the light or
what is it called I don't and but he was
very gassy or no no we were just talking
about it yeah it was brought up and
because you know is he was like he was a
safety he's in the alcohol for nine
years yeah and oh just gonna sleep late
at Florida State Cincinnati Cincinnati
and you guys and the Cardinals take this
that's what all psychics are like I want
to say Florida State Cincinnati
okay I was wrong to [ __ ] whatever I
don't time to listen now he's acting
he's I don't know where is yeah he's
probably know these are episode of with
him that's all right we're not gonna do
watch an episode of a podcast on a
podcast that'd be hilarious really not
what's the song called again oh dear I
remember we not friends
something the light [ __ ] finding the
light or chasing the light just put
light honey did you guys have a foot
races he was faster
I know I would have definitely uh he
tried to get me to do a push up the
contest like one of those challenges and
hearing all of those by the way [ __ ] out
my challenge now get out
give me a sitting on the couch watching
TV challenge where's you
song should play that for a second my
dad's song it's just friends by feather
on YouTube it's not like you up did you
find it by standing in the line standing
in the light that's what it is standing
what are you guys chasing the light of
this voice mad but it's not on YouTube
maybe just the audio noise maybe it's
not that bad it's not a it's not a Jason
Collings voice but all right Sarah - in
voice my god dude me and Chad we should
do an album dude good be album bro hey
you got our chins birthdays on Friday by
the happy birth the hell thank you his
voice is not bad guys yeah 31 thank you
32 I was gonna say 33 40 43 Wow
boy she's not bad well he's singing with
another person yeah yeah it's hard to
tell because they have those mics that
can change your voice too and say it's
different fun mics you know low dude no
he has a good voice minato sound like
he's auto-tune yeah how do you think cat
is cat is 21 47 47 how are you
ah 37 37 52 53 53 I get I took a year
off 333 similar age 41 hours late to the
party now you've been working three
years back down you look amazing thanks
man I got a young body I have a 23 year
old body yeah I just have you been doing
started it like 1819
that's where I met him and uh Chris it's
like the hot cafe he literally came up
to me and goes can I hang out with you
guys that's so cool well it was like two
of the most insecure it was me and Dalia
being so insecure thinking when we each
hated each other for no reason and then
him in the middle like a man being like
the [ __ ] are you two doing that's all he
was like I didn't think you liked me I
didn't think you liked me when we're all
open mic and in studs and then dude
Chris open for you it's Chris open for
me no no no no no they did the road
together Chris and I did I could want
his uh under no influence to her I did
that one
oh gosh it was but I was opening yeah
and then my time yeah
and there is it Chris was when I started
stand-up he was in about six months
he was about he's a six month common
when I'm talking to Lee I asked him why
he hasn't done our [ __ ] podcast to
ask him this say why would you do ro to
not do this he's the guest of the year
you got guests the year oh that's a good
boy who got guest of the year what do
you mean Chris did on that if you don't
want it I think two years in a row and
then they get a belt they get a dope
belt a nice lip sync battle but you got
a guest of the year just you gotta bring
it dude turn the [ __ ] I mean your
voice might do it I'm gonna do most army
songs start with no Aaron yeah hey
Michael McDonald is black - you know
when I call the class I just play saying
Michael McDonald was black yeah I don't
love to sing along but I don't know what
the funky thing dudes doing something
and then I want to see if Brian call you
no problem no no sorry go on your
Instagram you did I can't stand moving I
can't lower sir like feel it you can't
yeah kids down the right side my window
I can't stand the it's so bad hold on so
bad I can't stand the right oh if these
are glasses no we're doing with your
body
ah yeah yeah that's what that's you know
what that is that's right have to do so
many other things drinking and judging
you can't smash
do it without moving do it like this I
can't stand the rain sign my window
z-pak can't stand the ring dad my window
usually white guys have to do anything
else your thing else try to sing yeah
ready yeah girl I'm in love with you
honeymoon
honeymoon that's the in Statue of a John
Legend have a great voice that's all
tried to come out there and then it went
bad so if I really if I start warming it
up can see like classic rock that's more
yeah did you ever do goddamn come now
you're being nice to me no let me tell
you what it's actually really easy songs
you get really easy songs ladies Rock if
I warm up to my boys staring at it
that's good he did mother yeah you
mother yeah I did not to walk my way
tell your children not to hear my words
what they mean what they say
mother mother really enjoying it like
that I'm if I really want to sing it you
were literally the two of you are making
a face like you are watching your child
at a talent show and there you knew they
weren't good you know what's so oh
there's certain people nobody can sing
[ __ ] journey look at cat die that new
singer the journey has them to sing
order drinkin it's so hard as a Filipino
man
and the race is a cetacean he's so hard
to bury and there are no don't stop busy
I can't do it's not a great singer oh
that's a beautiful girl there those
chicks it's so hard
they are adorbs God is he it's a it's a
fascinating story they heard him just
singing karaoke on they saw him on
YouTube yeah they saw him on YouTube and
they went to the Philippines to see him
wow man
another photo for a second yeah that one
just all down
it looks like he trip for a second oh
[ __ ] take the photo take the photo
Miney what really bums you out that
picture yeah it's gotta be tough on that
pic I'd be tough to be there me who's
going to its job I would go oh yeah I
would go and pictures are all little
Pino rocking it out yeah okay he's good
have you seen what bring water
conference there's a there's a there's a
documentary on Netflix about oh really
what's again me the journey how does it
called journey to the journey it's it is
a reference to a journey song but I
can't remember what it's called okay mom
yeah hit it dude yeah that kid can say
man that's a great song someone would
say the best song I would kill ghost I
would rock the [ __ ] out to this hello
friends so you may have heard of me on
B's it's on every podcast any podcast
show this to me undies is all over you
know why because they're the best
underwear on the planet literally
designed their undies for comfort and
selfish you drunk that makes my 70 am I
drunk
there's no joy unhappiness there's no
question at all that the best underwear
on the planet on the planet where I
threw away almost all my other underwear
are me undies you understand me I just
said why because the way they they fit
and hold your 3p said and I got a piece
on me as you know got a piece I can't
let it just flop around you active I
wanna hold it but not squeeze it yeah
that's what I'm talking to made with
soft a sustainable fabric and
in sizes extra small for you but they
last for of Acts for me oh they last
forever - that's the other thing I've
had mine for like four years now they
look new oh my god they're fantastic
Nandi says great I'll for you guys for
any first-time purchases you get 50% off
and free shipping what this is a
no-brainer especially because they have
a hundred cent satisfaction guarantee
around the world 15% off and free
shipping my undies calm / fighter that's
my undies calm / fighter
I would chew I'll get Corona for this
this is driving music by the way in my
opinion like in the car I'm always lord
I live it down the beach yet going down
to panga Canyon yes many pianos many
pianos playing one of them like Yanni
you know too much smoke in his face -
he's like a guys I told you not to do
the smoke there in this part oh yeah
gives me chills Judy you're high for me
really it's what a great song still high
for me last year of college for Bryan
still he sounds just like it's crazy
what a story though it's got crazy what
everyone's want you can hear his accent
yeah yeah
nobody seems like Steve though no no
Papa he's saying that he's sang this
song at my house well my sister Sally
apparently I mean come on I asked him
about the song then he's saying the song
he goes yeah he was explaining how you
see it was written as a country song
this was hit in bars me and my sister
were like oh he goes so when you sing
let's say let the road it know and he
goes I sang it assayed and we were like
and he goes into it when I was like odd
so he's what else [ __ ]
hey I did a musical his cancer I didn't
know he had thyroid cancer he's fine I
did a musical and he was in the audience
oh that's with with my friend and we and
I I was seeing all my songs to him and
my friends were laughing so hard I'm not
a singer like it and I came out and I
started bowing like I was exhausted they
were laughing sorry of all the pictures
they could have done this guy's looks
like one of the boys now is face it's
like
I didn't know he was recovering from can
see it's got that whiskey puff [ __ ] I
didn't know that's me dude you said you
just met hey let me hear him sing it now
chin how way wrong yeah I would love to
be able to do that oh that's a beacon
kind of something huh I don't know the
words whatever do this song look watch
him Oh watch me grow my hair that length
is that cool yeah oh yeah do it if you
can do it I can do it do it don't worry
about hurting Brian's feeling Portuguese
by the way him yep yes yep Steve Perry's
Portuguese really I raised by mostly
women I think - what's that yeah he had
an interesting childhood are you alright
seeing this - a girl
can you imagine without anyone I wrote a
song you want to hear yeah I mean it'd
be hot in front of 80,000 buzz - this is
about think about it I always think
about when he wrote it and the people in
the room where he went you guys I did
this I did this tweak on this song let
me know what you think that's just the
piano intro alone yours look like you
and I were in the room what my my
co-star hey Leo rancha who's got a great
for sang she sang this original song he
and I I would have married her right
that I know we were in and Haley Santana
started singing and we were both like
Brendan just looked at Matt they're like
Brendan goes like this he goes oh my god
I go I know she's so good when people
can sing like that in front of you your
life the best [ __ ] man I know my wife
watches The Voice and I pretend I'm not
watching it but I walk through the room
and I watching this do do you watch
American Idol
you know no I've watched The Voice a few
times until there's a new sub there's
another show after The Voice where the
voice is great but it's karaoke I don't
see another yes they're singing other
people's songs yeah there's a song to
show after whether it's songwriters
that's right and they're submitting
their own original songs it's no thang
but a mr. Hardesty but on American Idol
because there's a kid who's on last year
who went I think he got second but he
did all original songs damn there most
the way so these kids who were original
like him like oh you can do that on
there so now that
filled of original artists when they
asked him to sing songs they oh I wrote
this myself play the piano y'all watch
those dunno you talk about that Spanish
kid
yes who drops in I said a trend oh Jesus
you see you can see that those people
who know music so well like Lionel
Richie is that one guys say they know
they're listening to something unique
and new and original there's a new guy
on here he moved for him I forget where
I forget where Africa no it's not black
he's like Indian he's Indian or
something like that but he has this
weird he is like this weird raspy voice
like a James I've heard him I'm her not
in Lionel Richie this is American Idol
yeah and like he gets done Lionel
Richie's like almost in tears it's like
this what this shows about is like wow
if you win this or not even of huge
career for me I know this attitude you
know Lionel in the 80s was on fire he
couldn't not write a hit yeah music
makes me religious like when I hear
great music I go like this I go there's
gotta be something more than just the
fact that we're smart monkeys like this
guy something how our minds able to do
yeah it's weird musically give me
emotional oh you know I'll try it
American Idol I have to have sound so to
have a soundtrack to my life when I'm
going on a walk I'm working out it's got
to be it so one of the find great art
that's in there our third gun yeah one
of the great ways to define great art is
the Duane Ichi Nietzsche and
Schopenhauer [ __ ] up Nietzsche yeah
are you do
you're drunk finish my great yeah that's
great
yeah driving home staying here all day
here's the best way to describe in my
opinion great art and it's not me imma
steal it from seniors no but but one of
the would you say emotional when you
hear great music now you see an amazing
movie when you when you see like a
[ __ ] painting Mitch's even greats
taalib even great sanap think what
happens what happened no no no I thought
well quietly say thank thank you that's
super annoying that that's really she
didn't know I said okay well it was in
my head I said okay you came out thank
you you know if I may mm-hmm so if you
were even great stand up yeah right you
you forget for a second that you're a
biological creature
meaning you forget about you have to
sleep that you're hungry and then you
want to [ __ ] you forget everything you
get that there's an Arrested Development
there's this arrested kind of like we
relief where you're just like and you
just forget for a second about all that
other stuff and that's how Nietzsche
described the only [ __ ] way to get
out of this cycle of being a human being
[ __ ] sleeping eating you know that
requires is art yeah it steps you out of
it that's the value among well how about
you saw it you know what sometimes it
goes sockless I'll tell you why I bought
these they're very expensive now I have
you keep saying that they're very
expensive but what are they going do so
my feet 6 out of 6 hooks so I have to
wear them because I won't get my like
rhythm without sometimes we make those
that's how you become like that become
you'd get the [ __ ] I'm sorry that's the
angry dad of me you're paying $600 of
those I did but I bought two others
those were 388 look because there is
used I never um used somebody more like
that 15 I'm a Nike guy I'm but I don't
like those I thought first for a minute
though very very old kid dressed but
apparently they're but look wait what
kind what are they called golden goose
okay I just want to make sure to
remember what never ever to buy but I
got it now now Brent what do you wear
where are you and where are you working
I'm an independent actor okay you know
what I mean like a Shia LaBeouf you know
I booted out that's very Shia LaBeouf
fish are you doing you doing a TV show
right now I did one it's canceled it was
so but I'm supposed to if this ever goes
away do another show for CBS wait nice
lead-in your show with Netflix right yes
what was it called merry happy whatever
okay well that sounds like you're mad
saying the title very happy whatever I'm
very good I'm just wondering if that was
Netflix of that of the whatever bad it's
a bad title we're we're I mean what do
you Pierce Morgan you can just ask the
question what is it about what would you
pay it's basically like it was basically
like Meet the Parents I was Ben Stiller
basically and Dennis Quaid was the
he's yeah I love him Jesus the Robert De
Niro always been oh I'm coming home
asking to marry her he doesn't want me
to so it's about me trying to win him
over I wrote a song for that show really
yeah maybe play a musician it's a multi
Kim I love doing multicam by the way any
work on his face
that's a minute nuts he's ripped still
buy though we're not so ripped no worth
much to that sceeto Chris Klein is that
Chris Pine who's that training it's
Hayes MacArthur you know him yes Hayes
is great look people in here Adam Rose
he's funny yeah and so is Lizzie
I'm gonna ask Amy to marry me I got to
be careful about who I let into this
family
I just need wasted I'm good enough drunk
any requests do you know this song not
now
part of it is just the stress of the
holidays I love physical comedy who is
that girl
favorite ashley tisdale sr bridgit
mendler loved ones pooja was his
girlfriend in the other show now you're
good actor Holliday yeah I came out a
Thanksgiving time yes you're a very good
actor actually thank you real that's why
I came here
wasn't your very good comedy you I never
saw you payment act yeah I was in film
school and I met these guys oh I just
did stand-up as a writer and then I just
fell in love we could stand ups the best
but I yeah I'd love to do great acting
you know I think you got another show
right well I got a pilot but we'll see
what happens what's what's that about
you play just some guy with a mustache
what do you play no they won't let me
have this no I don't know if I could say
a lot it's got Oliver Hudson and Malin
Akerman in it and me don't make me angry
don't make me angry with it's top secret
because I just don't know what I could
say I don't know anything I don't really
give our parading czar great but you
know what when are we all gonna be back
parading Japanese is great Japanese is
good one of the next Friday I'm gonna
get drunk don't drink all that we're
gonna drink a lot of it
fortunes birthday yeah for Jen's
birthday how nice I can't wait
we might sing some karaoke three I was
43 Wow nuts right it's insane you look
amazing
yeah thank you bro so yeah hey stay back
don't crack but what agent don't reason
Hazen don't know I love Rimes rhymes are
the whites of fright try to think of
good whites a fright are you a white guy
all the way are you all the way white
it's weird like something of dad would
ask Colin you look like you have
something else in you get some well I
did I did the 23andme and it was my mom
was born raised in England so it's 50%
English charm so your dinner's Italian
and
your first generation American yes oh
wow so you have the Italian side - yep
love it now Italian is actually
considered Caucasian probably which is
weird because they're really brown yeah
they are but it was defensive your
southern Italian yeah I'm southern
Italian mmm I'm all the way white yeah I
do have Native American but you get oh
you get a stop they used to think he was
when his name in the bling thought was
the hybrid before it changed a big brown
and [ __ ] hybrid the hybrid beak and they
thought because he was like a big brown
was your fighting late on that I thought
that's what you know they call hybrid he
gave me the nickname big brown and they
got so popular that there's AI love
change my name to big brown oh wow but
busy Brian they they thought by the
first hybrid a lot of people thought he
was like a hybrid like they was like a
bro I mixed two I'm black and white and
Brett I'm feeling no that's not what it
means I'm [ __ ] physically you know
what was the meaning of behind calling
hybrid athletics right yeah high because
I was a big guy that moved like a little
day yeah nice and then that blame Toyota
hybrid so funny [ __ ] I don't why God
just watching TV and you're like who
gave you the hybrid foot the the UFC the
Ultimate Fighter producers oh really
yeah how would you do that I don't know
a lot about it
have you said too long Oh too long think
of it seven seven years Pro um how long
he been a stand-up for years now five
years oh he said for years did he it was
like I would watch him quietly suffer
just the [ __ ] stress of fighting
monsters how much better stand up
I don't wanna never do there anything
ever people always ask me are you
nervous when you go on stage you can't
be no because for so long you want to
hear every November's up the cloudy
store really open because your peers or
began because you got a sizable cops
legs there look at the size of his
[ __ ] legs cuz it Pierce's wait who's
that
that's Mirko Cro Cop crazy-ass linear
come from college and I've stopped I
stopped watching all this stuff he was a
beast stop watching all this stuff yeah
but but but stand up it to me it's just
not you might not get any more manly
than Mirko Cro Cop mmm he was like a
special forces on the guy and everything
really yeah yeah it's just he's as tough
as he gets he's the biggest baddest you
know I love about this podcast is that
you can go from singing love songs and
crying to journey and then and then a
little bit of racism mixed with
accidental racism by the way I said I
know my people are accidentally racist
oh hi - we do believe we are as Korean
always on accident like white people are
the owner rates people addresses is
another race for Halloween Halloween is
your Brian I don't know cholo arrests
afar in I don't know black people don't
do that I will be probably you know no a
lifeguard or ski instructor ya know
black guys be a white guy which would be
awesome like you never seem to go away I
will be a beekeeper this year dog a
white faith hey let's say this search
engine is hilarious I had a dream about
be honest yeah oh yeah that sasural
thinks whitefish new foods blond-haired
asses what's that oh he did it well
remember do you remember the old hat -
now sketch with Eddie Murphy yeah like I
go silly Negroes see ya let's do some
current events Jim sure see what these
guys about Eddie Murphy as well like Oh
oh my god
yeah remember that was such a great
sketch dude you are when Jimmy Kimmel
was black faces quorum alone yep yes it
was like a sketch oh honey please nobody
said [ __ ] I won't say anything all there
is it's funny nobody said [ __ ] about
money if it's if it's been done fire it
is right there
that's know pretty hardcore
that's black body that's not being the
offensive that's being [ __ ] funny the
ignore the ignore the [ __ ] that
comedy is dancing well he was with
Whoopi garland I'm sorry what Ted dance
is doing there
that's some racist yeah he was dating
Whoopi yeah survived it this is these
days with social media he can't survive
that [ __ ] he's dating Whoopi so he
wouldn't black Jimmy Kimmel's good is
that annoying Brian yes I guess Jimmy
Fallon Fox themselves yeah the cancel
court culture is kind of over now with
is it yes I've done women because I hope
so cuz I got some [ __ ] to say it's
always white guys who are like white
people who are like in academia who are
like raising the alarm
I would Kurt eventually got alright I'm
not paying attention by the way okay so
an Australian woman the other day posted
up an old vacation photo of her and her
husband they were off in an island back
in 2019 for vacation
somebody who saw that photo reported her
to the authorities and she got fined a
thousand 1600 Australian dollars for
reaching the lockdown even though it was
a throwback picture yeah they're just
they found out later
they're just job after investigating
that it was an old photo so they took
away the fine and said hey maybe just
don't post on Instagram go [ __ ] yourself
we need this well I'll post whatever I
want we need to be reminisce right now
you have to be nuts doubt I'll tell the
authorities go [ __ ] themselves I can
post whatever I wanted to [ __ ] feel
also who's reported that photo from your
group of friends do you know the girl
that's actually dating her husband no
I'm gonna [ __ ] these two up right now so
that's crazy
do you see the the mayor of New York
said it it's law now it's law now you
gotta wear a mask outside they're
starting that in LA too
we're in New York said New York I mean I
I
I will understand doing it in I wear a
mask when I go into stores in LA I get
that but if I'm outside on the sidewalk
keeping my distance I think that's too
ridiculous I think it's yeah if you go
in order where there's a bunch of people
just throw the mask on I put it on my
chin yeah yeah but I think that when you
start dictating that I have to do that
on the street and I'm keeping my
distance New York though is hard to keep
your distance I mean yeah make sense all
around also New York is now the
epicenter of not just America but the
entire world for coronavirus yeah yeah
they're like the center but they also
have this big moment is around homies
yeah bunch of [ __ ] Ronnie Ami's Ronnie
Ronnie Ronnie Tony's running around in
New York that's what's going on so a man
in Indiana went to go check his ATM but
his balance at ATM and he found that he
has eight point two million dollars in
his account
yeah he was crunk yeah there's a
stimulus thing right and they sent all
of it to one dude boom immediately but
you have to pay that back if you did
withdrawing it well the tax on all that
[ __ ] too right yeah are they doing the
stimulus checks are they is it going al
around or am i coughing day and got got
there's how much 1,200 bucks 1200
minutes 1200 per person like so if
you're if you got two or three people in
a household that are making mile that's
cool yeah I think yeah that's cool it's
tax-free those you don't but if you
don't if you didn't set up direct
deposit with your account or whatever
whoever however you do your tax returns
it's gonna take longer to get a check on
the yeah if you have direct deposit you
get it immediately yeah people are
starting to get them like now that's
awesome yeah yeah the only thing about
that I a lot of people are angry about
is that if you haven't paid child
support payments then you don't get it
hmm lay on your child well you know what
give it to the child if you don't be a
kid be PA mom yeah get some Jordans for
that kid you know ya have a kid don't
have kids you use zero yeah I know I got
a lot of kids just seven claim them who
knows I don't know I don't pay any
attention but you know it's brand-new
one right above four month old hundred
five
Wow so many of the hobbies were you
don't pay by month yeah you yes Tripoli
just had two new ones two twins and
Russell Peters just had a baby had a
baby while you just turned a year old
but yeah it's mine just turns 30
why yeah I have a 30 year old in a 25
year his son yeah he's got a great fit
where he goes you're not an adult I have
a guy said I don't have kids I have
people yeah I have roommates that don't
pay rent that's right not just citizens
have two dudes at my house like what's
up that on my [ __ ] you dude what's up
unemployment that's what do they do
one of them is a photographer so he's
broke and then the other one a graphic
artist graphic designer but is also in
the CBD business he's in the cannabis
industry yeah he's uh did you say you
don't you know you're not an adulterer
you can look your son the I just say
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know you know one
it's you never think about this when you
have kids one day I'm gonna look at that
kid no [ __ ] you yeah boys girls or boys
huh
yeah that's mine and two boys were you
know I got a girl and a boy karma both
our mo transition so okay so we don't
yeah I'm forcing it on them because I
want to be good that's good I want to be
written up in [ __ ] People magazine no
no no kids in the future you know don't
chant honestly Rona man don't know
thanks dad
don't make him say don't ever do it I
like me no see I was on that riot app
and then that's done and then ten times
I rise right away I gotta hear about a
lot of people that brush it on man yeah
I was it was great on there it was great
I was on there but I was at the Comedy
Store one night and I let I let you know
the waitresses there that worked there
they're all friends you know they just
want to see what it was like and they
it's my fault that I gave him my phone
and said yeah whatever you could look at
it and then they just wrote like some
funny thing I think this is what I think
why the next day I was banned but then I
guess somebody wrote like I like pizza
and my butthole to some girl like just
some jealous and I guess it was enough
that got me banned where I'm like okay
then fine I'm banned all right that's
done whatever now I have to walk around
ha
wondering who was it and did that spread
like are people gonna be like oh there's
bread because I don't know who it was
kicked off on riot feel a little dirty
like a dick pic you sound creepy
I write the st. hi I know what an
original start in parentheses is all I
write to start so I was like you could
just do some evidence and see that I'm
not writing that shitty so but after
that tinder they won't believe it's me
which is [ __ ] crazy because I'm not
famous like that's that doesn't work but
I can't get laid on there so now is it
Gumbel to Gumbel honesty I [ __ ] hate
those app what about foreign want to
meet someone in person yeah but here's
the problem farmers only I won't on a
farm is only date and it was like seven
acres was a driveway and then no one was
there just a bunch of pumpkins on fire
no the quarantine you can't date like
there's nothing to do so I'm just with
my thoughts sketching yeah brilliant
things is that so this is Michael Buble
and his wife she's pretty they went on a
live Instagram live and there is a clip
where they're introducing themselves
saying hi and a lot of people took this
clip and are now saying that Michael
Buble is abusive to his wife just watch
check it out for yourself again oh and
meme wee-wee in the Amiga yes pasa why
does it do what do you guys think though
cuz they are roughhousing they're
[ __ ] why you had a plan and I think
we let's watch it again I watch her face
or let you cause just try me again I
pray hit a bit I mean we mean that me
you should say sorry too though however
you never know she might be into it I
started joking around she into it hold
me down and hurt me or let us just like
me get what I said sorry yeah right you
might just be a badass damn down in
right hang around don't [ __ ]
interrupt me again in the life here
if you [ __ ] interrupt being in alive
we're gonna have a problem yeah anyway
so Chico's was aggressive for sure it
was it was aggressive but he's a good
son unless we can say he hits her yeah a
lot of people are taking an old
interview that he did talking about how
he was raised with a lot of abuse and he
himself as an angry guy they don't see
this and I know you so well I can tell
by the sound of your voice that you're
really afraid of me
you should be hey it's one of his all
right fine but man oh man yeah that's
hard to tell he's tough to tell he's
fine gun to the head she did seem a
little scared but yeah really yeah
though like this not you know you need
my elbow where I went like that come on
I threw a pillow at my wife this is my
felt like [ __ ] yes but I did it out of
anger we weren't having a pillow fight
that was hard yeah yeah hey fools are
back over and if you notice his only
grabbing where you can't see bruises I
know the technique what's that grifters
where he's she's she's sitting there and
and he starts putting oranges into a
pillowcase and he's like this oh now why
do I put oranges in a pillowcase and she
goes because she hue and you hit
somebody the insurance you break bones
but you leave no bruises just like
somebody technique will you put oranges
in a pillowcase and he's smiling and
telling us okay you don't know that
movie remember that movie grifters I
haven't seen it in places my mom boss
and anjelica huston at the 80s oh dude
[ __ ] ya know who was in it it's a
great movie John Cusack and and what the
[ __ ] oh that was a
ah great movie Annette Bening it's a
great matter this she's so hot in it oh
my god is she so close to the older
movie oh yeah but it's for Academy one
other I missed that Orica Academy Award
nominations great movie
you said 33 movie yeah he's baby 3300
same I think 30 what else you got Chris
Cuomo oh he's gone wrong he's got the
runs got aronia and then he was also
doing his thing
he's great too I love I have kind of
cover crushed I feel like everybody I
have a little bit of a brothers the
mayor of this brother it's his brother
brother his father was Mary Oh Cuomo who
had to it was the late governor of New
York got it
so Chris and his brother grew up in
Gracie Mansion mm-hmm
so so but Chris was a Chris I knew Chris
back in the day great guy and just a
dumb man's man because you're better
anything to me except for basketball
yeah he thinks they're out there in the
villages that's not true they're dead he
was that's not true
he was even dad said it so better
everything but that's not that's not
true they're dead serious so funny yeah
I love Chris Cuomo because he he dude he
doesn't hold back when he's interviewing
people think it was that crazy Trump
lady Kellyanne Conway her when do you
get when he's when he goes in on her
hilarious well when he's got that weird
subliminal sarcasm and you can tell our
caste R D there's kinda like a bulldog
yeah yes I bring it he's a great is
adorable anyways because I serous s sm f
XM yesterday XM show and then he was
talking about CNN and I'll just play for
now I love his radio show cuz he swears
I see when he interviews the circulars
here we go I don't want to spend my time
doing things that I don't think
van are valuable enough to me personally
hmm
like what well I don't like what I do
professionally I've decided so he's
basically talking about his CNN show
like he wants to be able to say whatever
he wants to say but he can't deny his XM
show yeah Syria is the [ __ ] cuz he's
like this is [ __ ] like swear on it
yeah I get that yeah for him yeah so
that's what I said about CNN but then he
also went off on some guy I guess there
was a bike bicyclist guy riding around
his house and you know Chris is supposed
to be quarantined in the basement well
he has he had the wrong room yeah with
his/her own road he's supposed to be
quarantine and away from his family so
this bike rider saw him in front of his
yard with I guess his wife another woman
and the kids like together so the guy
would chart a hassle on cuz they do ask
you CNN so I think we're all know but
then again you know we all know that
he's not really a stayin away from
family right
that is bicylist should leave - don't
[ __ ] yes yes this doesn't deserve a
for sure you bring in a fight to him mr.
Cuomo will is is a big athletic strong
he's a strong dude good take a look at
what Chris lips language is just
cyclists saying that he was bullied by
Cuomo yes because Oh first of all if you
come to my house exactly yeah that's not
both it was like a hundred feet away and
you got your kid with you fine no I'm
bald yeah everybody yeah [ __ ] that but
so Chris was like you know I can do
whatever I want to do and then I'll see
you again soon you know something gonna
happen like I follow the police report
against Chris you guys a [ __ ] he says
lightening him what he said he did it
just so it's on record he's not gonna
press charges but it's not record but
yes reduce but also know what I closed a
also in this day and age he's trying to
get followers I was 65 year old guy he
wants to know what CNN's gonna do about
him saying exactly that's I'm wondering
- then I can do [ __ ] no she has a hit
show he could say what he that's what
you could say the faces in it yeah well
let's get after it that's what he says
let's get after it
I love that right what you want me to
lit up I'm gonna start off with we all
know you want to
his body we're all gay you haven't
problem our little game a little game a
little game that be Chris oh yeah I
believe that he's holding that chris has
always been a fighter he looks like when
he screams yeah that's how he was how
would I know he was better stuff not in
house I look yellow
that's I'm by the way Joe brother his
brother the governor of he was about the
same way your than him um [ __ ] huge
big boys
yeah I'm Jake [ __ ] boys yeah that's
so that's annoying so annoying every bit
every bit of six to call are you me I'm
6 4 4 we also yeah Janice lauch let's
see Oh Amy Schumer named her baby after
Dave Attell cuz you know that's one of
her a good friend oh that's great
all right let me however when she
combined the name she realized it
sounded like something bad so wait her
name heard the baby's name was Jean a
tell so if you combine hills Lords yes
change the name she's gonna change it
after that school Gina tell ya
and then Jesus also hey figure it out
would they name it now so now it's it's
also dream it's a dream that's real name
is now but yeah they changed name so
they left it would be yeah I do yeah oh
that's funny she's probably doing as a
joke okay alright Brian we're sorry we
just make a little so comedy got some
babies welcome back to Brian's baby
touching comedy club I heard about this
guy - alright
oh no these these things a pastor that
was defiant against the whole CDC
recommendations of not having a whole
group together he said I want to keep
having massive groups together for my
food and prayers and he said God's above
everything else he's older for sure yeah
if you're
holder in it because Co vid 19 goes
after the old and black so you got over
19 true it goes after a lot of a lot of
people black people in certain parts of
the country are more overweight because
their have lower income so lower-income
people tell you I have a problem and
it's also in line that obesity is a big
[ __ ] factor in you should also in
lower expose they're all living on top
yeah in the lower-income neighborhoods
they're all living on top of that's also
true generations your grandmother lives
in the house but if you have the Lord in
your life that's a sad story it's a sad
story regardless but it's it's
interesting that he was the one that was
defiant and then is it weird to say okay
it's sir it's not good way to go
universe with population control okay
this is why we don't get me some whiskey
before hold on here that's sad I feel
worse for the bus driver remember the
bus driver which was a bus driver that
went online and posted a video about how
people kept getting on his bus coughing
and coughing and coffee and he was
completely who's he gotta end he died oh
yeah that's underlying hold out of shape
and he was he's 101 101 oh my god
this is I just think this is funny cuz
so where I carried did this live
performance at home was it a nightmare
oh these was not a nightmare here dude
she's a live performance have been tough
so this is I'm not sure if it was
engineered you know the audio but it
seemed really well
really well done and then the only thing
I was laughing at is if you see like
she's in her at home would you see like
air blowing in her hair oh yeah I
thought that was from the fan on chin
yes but I mean a fight yeah she's trying
to do something she makes for a dramatic
lights change how about the way she
sings it's good and I like the sign
language that she does a lot with it she
doesn't eat her own signer man what
what an instrument what an instrument 9
who's awaiting your album sing with her
chin I feel like she's that good where
they could probably do it and then
someone's engineering sound she's got an
amazing she's amazing she was one thing
this very few people get hit it's uh
yeah she has that whistle tones all she
could do it Brendan Philip Bailey from
Earth Wind & Fire can do it I can't do
it I was auditioning for well not our
disco they wanted me to do Frankie Valli
or like audition for Frankie Valli and I
couldn't hit that note I call Jase and I
go I can't do this [ __ ] man this is just
not my thing then he calls me goes
what's I can't I'm like what are you
talking about I go you mean you know
how's it going man so I can't hide you
want some more uh let's see so Joaquin
Phoenix is Cuomo Andrew Cuomo to release
prisoners you know if it's not like
anything big for it's a misdemeanor or
not named a misdemeanor something else
like something low-level crime is like
interrupts possession yeah yeah he wants
him to release low risk low risk but
he's on it the spread of coronavirus and
prisons threatens the health and safety
of all of us is he reading yes and your
incarcerate that's not asking to such
things he's looking straight the camera
cars ensuring good hygiene is not an
option it really cares about that yeah
he doesn't he seems passionate a super
passion I like his energy I a man
becoming ill and spreading the virus I'm
calling on governor and I said it here
on yeah good silver-fox I'm okay what I
love about TMZ is they have that
distracting side banner she's like oh it
works I got a question about him that I
might be way it might be way off on this
or behind does even hair look yes yes or
not yes scar there how dare you my eyes
just focused right to his top lip I'm
like born with a cleft palate
yes grow a mustache yeah yeah it kinda
yeah well does he know I'm not sure I
remember as a kid in that movie
Parenthood with Steve Martin
actor yeah this is when you yes have
something common babies oh yeah it's 45
45 years old oh wow
hello what else you got I saw this
amazing floor tweet Florida's wild dude
Florida is wild right now they don't
give a [ __ ] killed him in the next said
this guy was released because of
coronavirus you know potentially getting
into this the prison and affecting one
else so he was released early on a drug
charge and they killed someone the next
day odd and then just if you look at the
guy gonna kill let him out early yeah
and his defense a lot of rappers these
days have face testers and rich white
kids you're emotional you know also
tattoos are about as edgy as cargo pants
these different everyone has yeah but
what's going is Texas yeah face tattoos
do also some says I'm gonna kill a man
that says I'm gonna kill him in there
there's a lot of mental illness that
colored said journey back yeah Steve
Perry's the don't stop Steve Perry Steve
and then Perry on the other side have
you guys heard about this the all in
challenge no so it's just well these big
okay Leonardo DiCaprio a lot of these
celebrities are giving like
once-in-a-lifetime opportunities to
people that are donate to this cause and
it's for Tom Brady providing food to
those in need kids elderly and frontline
heroes which is great love it and
there's a bunch of different bids you
could do what's the Tom Brady one I
think black join him born and raised in
New England mandali that Joe goddamn it
he's happy not look good Jesus rice yeah
you know he looked real shitty is Rookie
Yahoo and including work real shitty I
got money then he got money like time
expiry money's the best lotion baby look
at that those teeth down to Tampa Bay
already has that Florida thank you
look at how named hopefully you enjoy it
we'll get a looking day experience is
the best man you got back at a crush on
them oh yeah I do
dinner or workout following one dinner
no we're doing a workout it's a little
much what's the highest bid oh there's
some crazy bid so thanks crazy greatest
a so here's opening this 50 grand
what and then meet Mel's give me always
phantom and the opening bids two hundred
thousand what's the Kevin Hart won Kevin
Hart yeah great opportunities doing here
is yeah Kevin Hart here and I want to
say that I accept the all-in challenge
that's right I accept it what you guys
doing is an amazing thing
raising over a hundred million dollars
to feed the world and this crazy time of
me the corona virus has taken us all by
storm
and to find some type of relief is a
must so I'm gonna do my part that's
right I am gonna do my part here's what
I'm bringing to the table I would
provide a movie star experience for sad
individual and by movie star experience
I want you to understand what I'm saying
here I'm talking about giving somebody a
speaking role in my next move speaking
role a trailer you will have an
assistant you have a car service
I'm gonna do the full shebang baby he's
great dude his confessions from the
heart that he does on Instagram are
great although that's a much different
movie tik-tok Charlet yeah yeah I didn't
know about that yo she got she was on
Fallon because you got tick tock family
crazy no I'm like wow what is this
amazing thing that she's she's so famous
she just it's one dancer hey I'll do
they're all like this they're all going
like this and then they get millions of
views what well yeah they're all shaking
their ass look at it you want to watch
theirs yeah yeah alright let's see what
this is that's wrong look which means
famous I think they're both team the one
on the right the one talking someone's
mystic talk storm starry and all she
does is dance dance so we're trying to
get their 15 the baby I think she's 15
her older sister is years older let's be
safe and say seventeen say for who
the waters guys yeah it's amazing
who's this you wanna see fun yeah this I
think it's kind of funny but also kind
of concerning so hopeful for you what's
going on guys just here I just wanted to
say held hostage did you join the all it
looks a little weird right
I am going to auction off a goose sounds
great well yes that's nothing who the
winners home and I sing them also
covered up what does have a wrong for
them be cool at their home that's a big
deal unity more energy be fun for me I
can't want to do it right this is an
amazing thing that these celebrities
know it's great yeah we should we should
try to put ourselves in a steel snack
yet I don't think the Tom Brady ones the
best gig I mean I would that would be
every time yes I'm Kevin babe Tom Brady
gear coming really yeah
see now I got a roofer Tampa this year
me too you from New England were you
from Hartford Hartford Connecticut
mmm-hmm I know it we added oh we mean
Hartford now I'm from New Jersey
California area and you're all wrong
with this Jersey California so that Liz
oh that's Liz oh and the P Diddy
he did he did like a online Instagram
live dance party where everyone joined
in and so there's controversy here
because he made Liz oh stop twerking cuz
she's good
oh sorry go ahead but the controversy
good PD but go ahead alright so I'm
gonna play the video him with first
people is oh I appreciate you to feed it
for doing that but go ahead as they
going together some dancin that's P
Diddy on top with his family
oh okay I know why and then she's
twerking right now is it for kids yeah
it's for kids yeah it wasn't for they
say clean he's had a family friendly
family friendly so anyways that was part
of it and then but then they you know
fans found another video of another girl
and Riya she's hot and he didn't stop
her this is love here
yes that she's smoking hot smoke cooking
up she's adorable
who the [ __ ] she's best of all lives
yeah she's I'm bout she's so bad
Wow God and her booty so let me guess
she does it and he's totally good with
it yes I'll say there's a little bit
there and the Internet is undefeated huh
oh just fine anything you do especially
now with the live stuff
everyone's quarantined defense in this
one it did he say it was for kids - I
mean there's balloons in the baby okay
have you never seen no no I mean I get a
little more color on her alright so he
show this time he cuts it it goes cut
cut cut the music hey can you do your
phone he didn't stop her I'll continue
to do that a whole lot it was Liz oh man
no no she's not mad at all but there's
controversy cuz they think he's stopping
Liz oh because she's trying to keep you
sane it's cuz the music in the
background was cut out Hispanic and if
you listen to it back let's switch song
yeah yeah hey good save he did actually
pulled that out of his ass right away
anyway wow that was good yeah he's got a
good team working for him that's for
sure
Basketball Wives your said hurt what the
[ __ ] is around is she - Riya
oh yeah right or she is hold on what the
she is also newly single oh yeah well I
don't know if she's gonna know she can
go for any well I'm just saying like a
basketball star and then you know me
with a mustache that's like a weird
transition oh she's up five so she's
pretty good-looking oh that's a nice
picture dyno award alright and she can
dance yeah booty - that's impossible
that's painful yeah [ __ ] is going on
yeah I'm quarantine can we stop look at
those pretty eyes oh one last thing this
this happened in Poland Oh take that oh
wow oh it's gonna be Jason on the way
home
that's how I always want to drive when I
see roundabouts yeah so it's a
roundabout see the rather India it's
roundabout she demands everything worse
they're so confusing to be okay if there
was a swing that happen in Poland whoa
but it was so hot they did that upheaved
I know you gotta be ready this Ross
applies to get him out honestly whenever
I see something like this this is how I
picture my son driving my car he wasn't
paying attention obviously I think he
might have been alcohol how did you miss
the giant fast
here's a good [ __ ] if you landed on all
fours to this land land land land
Poland Poland yeah I've never undergone
I give up that's amazing actually
yeah some engineer was hired to put all
roundabouts and all the intersection I
know I hate Delhi India and it's
terrible how you say everything have you
seen New Delhi now versus 2019 take a
look at take a look at the what the smog
so for the Bears they're able to see the
Himalayas no she didn't do Delhi's the
most pop most polluted city in the world
2019 to now so the there are indexes
that at nine hundred sometimes they get
you know it's dangerous yeah a lot
clearer - yeah I got a lot of side but
it's true watch this is that core after
blow your mind yeah there was that
picture of it there's a picture of it
before and after Himalayans you're a
good typist
no knows me after covin of Isis oh you
found it this no it's like a smoker on
them it was yesterday it was yeah it's
positively Allison yeah let's look
through here yeah there you go so so
wait so now show it stick that's what it
looked like see sucio smoggy that [ __ ]
is huh that's pretty cool look at what
it does it's crazy
oh wow that's a compatible look at that
[ __ ] Jesus so there are pros to this oh
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah there's a lot of
people more pros and cons in my opinion
were out of control
wow yeah what are you I'm gonna do I
want to jump the the roundabout now
well fellas hey you coming down man even
these crow now let's keep doing this no
no we are in a meter okay
oh [ __ ] yeah cuz Brian told us Brian
it'll check me yo yes that was nowhere
to park right is there anywhere to park
he goes and you said it like this
nope yeah and then we get here and I'm
like there's a is a private possibility
for - sorry never Park there's not too
much time the gate you just have too
much time bat that lazy I am now your
podcasts the Lions of lions yeah and
with Brent Morin and Jason Collins yeah
dude
alright guys absque Ribe listen rate
review yeah that all the things that we
were told to say my all our friends
Vince a lot of foam you get we get
emotional we talk about real things and
we get silly it's all the [ __ ]
I'll be your guest guys interview want
we're coming into commerce all right
yeah you want ratings I got you here
yeah I guess are you gonna give me one
of these again yeah sure I got you I see
you there good cat daddy appreciate you
guys man okay I'll do it thanks for
having us man yep
is that it - that's it yeah Friday bonus
show when does it come out I'm gonna
drive this comes out today oh yeah what
do you guys you shoot and then what
takes a few days we we shoot our Monday
episodes usually on Sunday and then we
do bonus and then we do a patreon [ __ ]
on Monday okay I'm confused
well are we so on nope it's a bun kid
we're out